ciao ragazzi inventor rete una puntata
del guglielmo tell e il format nel quale
attraverso instagram
gli chiedo di farmi sapere che cosa
potrei fare all'interno del mio video e
all'interno del quale cerco di fare più
cose possibili su due volte stupide
senza senso e mortificanti ma dal
momento che non ho più una dignità tipo
da sei anni posso andare tranquillo
perché non ho più nulla da perdere e
siamo a leggere subito cosa mi arrivato
trova una morosa a enrico che riccò già
trovato da un anno si può dire ti piace
essere una star misteriosa e sempre
single tra parentesi sentiamo tutti
quanti paola se poi la scrive enrico
errico subito lì se tu gli scrive enrico
non l'ho letto che ormai scriverò a
paola di scrivere enrico di fare delle
cose tristi all'ultimo se mi è rimasta
la canta il testo di una canzone sulla
melodia di un'altra sere nere voglia di
ballare un rack in spiaggia voglia di
nevers tipi tra le mie braccia per fare
tutto quello che non si poteva
karaoke guantanamera a me mi piace la
nutella e cela decollata e merendine in
quantità commovente addio scherzo
telefonico alice okami nella quale
chiede di fare un video con te facendo
cose schifose però io odio gli scherzi
telefonici odio farli mai
non rispondo non è possibile mettere
fine lo sta facendo altro
o mi odia ciao eri nuda stati assegnati
fuori no stai aspettando la chiamata di
qualcun altro
senti anni di voler proporre una cosa
non ti andrebbe di fare un video insieme
di un format nuovo che sta facendo sul
mio canale praticamente tipo un'unione
tra vita buttata e cucina buttata quindi
praticamente noi dobbiamo tipo ascoltare
le vocali mentre pian piano l'ospite
viene immerso in una vasca di burro
sembra strano però nel caso però non è
non è così e tipo a seconda di ogni
commento che io ricevo io prendo una
cosa dal frigo e la devo mettere la
vasca da bagno cioè tipo una piscinetta
in realtà ovviamente è goliardico e poi
tu le risposte te le devi scrivere in
fronte è un po confusa così no non è
piena di burro può essere burro che ne
so qualcuno dice metti le tre uova in
testa e lei delle tipo e tirarsi i
capelli è una cosa per te ma si chiamerà
persona buttata cioè praticamente tu fai
una cosa per cui tu alla fine
oggi la dignità vedevo caridi poi ha
perso i conti non sa più che cosa può
morire a farti questa cosa parties che
se ti va di farlo dai per fortuna non ha
risposto in reggiseno avresti fa avresti
alzato sicuramente le visualizzazioni
questo canale
la professionalità fatti trovare sì
diciamo pronta per la festa a villa ma
certo tipo tre quattro regni
non lo so seguite tutti alice perché noi
la sequenza vi lascio tutti i link qui
fa un sorriso di padre tante e
sponsorizzato
già un bacio ali confessa a tutti noi il
vero super poteri di gul dino prendiamo
per vedere a tutti quanto il tuo vero
super potere se pronto piedi qui una
ragazza mi scrive consigli di vita tre
anni e mezzo di relazione non conosco
nella sua famiglia nel nulla e
nonostante le quindi a lei quindi è una
ragazza è stata una ragazza e poi non ha
più continuato ripetute ripetutamente
che a lei le avrà detto niente ora
voglio parlare questo consiglio perché
secondo me basta solamente l'inizio per
dirti ha dei problemi nel dichiarare il
fatto di essere gay e quindi mostrarti
anche solo come amica i genitori oppure
c'è un problema di relazione insomma tre
anni e mezzo sono anche tanti alberto
computer vergognare della famiglia che
ne sai davvero per esempio quando ti
vergognavi le inizi a balcanizzare penso
io con paola compra il primo libro nei
best seller di amazon fu sera e fu
mattina di ken follett perché folle se
non è bravissimo posto il prequel dei
pilastri della terra i gusti pilastri
della terra ma non lo voglio più
comprare dimostra un po di affetto a
gianmarco enrico e la vigna fallo però
in maniera sbagliata
r ti chiedo scusa per quello che ho
detto su the paola perché comunque penso
che se sei brutto un altro dovrebbe far
notare johnnie to e tutte le persone
senza un futuro se la mia preferita è la
linea che sta guardando questo video
vari volte ho detto che eri stupida
brutta antipatica poco modesta e che il
russo ti sta malissimo in realtà volevo
dirti che il rosso di sta bene
associa ogni membro della scilla squad
ad un personaggio disney lavinia
crudelia de mon enrico pumbaa no ma wi
fi come uil diverse cose nelle righe
diverse cose la disney bambino forse il
bambino di aprea bravissimo marco
merlino esile alto e che rompe con il
maggiordomo di eric della sirenetta gol
di official vg io sto dicendo cava
tarzan perché non parla italiano
gabriele gaston sia ma anche scar quello
che sotto sotto avrebbe uccideremo fase
il suo fratello maggiore tutu dio io
sono bella bisogna bestia 2
il proprietario della cagliari 101 ma è
un cretino doris ore ho pagato e gul
dhoest i cerchi identico i denti o
dichiarati in dm al vip uomo più seguito
che ti segue io tramite averci la
ragazza e sam schmidt connesse wayne
smith non so per quale ragione che
l'uomo
veramente non so di colplay quelli no no
no no no lui è quello che è
ecco perché ti segue vorrei tornare però
mai mi voglio rovinare il fatto che una
persona e che quindi automaticamente
dirà questo è un [ __ ] ti amo ha
capito cosa ha visto dei video scritto a
volte sotto deposta che erano super
carino e ti amo sennò poteva andare e
dire che gli aiuti amato dai ragazzi
per favore prendi tre libri aprile a
caso e leggi la quarta parola della
prima frase e poi con le parole forme
una tua frase l'angri generi fantasy un
horror è un romanzo spendere due parole
per loro questo non è un video
sponsorizzato lo sapete ve lo direi
ma questi nación sigrun nachos bayelsa
porcili nei vasti nachos averla casa
fonda speciale pure come terramare
pessime benissimo veloce perché questo
non l'ho ancora letto letto incubo
faccia speciali veloce faccia sei
speciale vieni veloce di pace
mima una canzone ad enrico che deve
indovinare il titolo vi faccio tre
canzoni ragazzi mentre due indovinare un
vincere fa il meglio su tre e mezzo
scappato con la musica
abbattiamo sole cuore amore
mamma mia
5 bella come cazzo mondo o quasi
notte prima degli esami bravissimo che
sembra visti con 0 vanno da gianmarco
scegli i nomi dei gattini ragazzi mi
dispiace ancora non li ho trovati e ci
sta che hanno chiesto perché ti vorrei
in coppia i più carini sono stati pena e
panico lady oscar
perché sono maschi e femmina cosi e nega
se scopo si nega mi piace un sacco tacci
tua fatemi sapere qua sotto dei commenti
mettete i like a quelli che vi piacciono
così almeno li vedo sopra e riesco a
farmi un'idea incontro culto gatti
stiamo andando con gould all'interno
della stanza possibilità culto siamo
pronti a entrare nella stanza brevità
non o cercare cercare via via via tutti
a tutti lui proprio non sta reagendo
bene giù giù giù bravo bravo non so se
l'è vista non esiste avvicinando
all'inizio come vacanza dopo l'insperato
per meno pazzo del male lo bravissimo
centro calibrava inception dove l'altro
è bravissimo che aspetti loro tempi no
seduto buono diversità dopo avevo tante
il cane sprezzante interiore lei
studiosa le il mio del ranger lawler
unione fufi è riuscito l'esperimento che
ampiano che ti aspettavi che entravo qui
e loro davvero per cantavano insieme al
karaoke
ho già un foglio sulla tua schiena e
cerca di indovinare cosa ci disegnano
sopra facciamolo un pisello e un pisello
è un pisello bravo è un albero è una
nuvola
cos'è questo un sorriso valvo ha dato di
nuovo uno smile
ma come potrei pensare che lo capisci
questa cosa questa sede di napoli queste
le tette no non piegandosi che qualcuno
sta facendo qualcosa fuori verso il
trattore mi chiedevo scusa andiamo
avanti con questo movimento non ha senso
che stai facendo è un oggetto utilizzato
spesso il film horror coltello cattivo
gusto e cattivo gusto come non bastavano
foto un pisello
sono indeciso tra un boccale di birra un
ragazzo è chiaro no è la monnalisa come
cazzo è una forma semplice e poi come
questo va bene che cos'è
ma no gianmarco e il gol di maradona che
ha fatto col che una mano fa pubblicità
malato crema per i ricci come farebbe
mastrota signori signore ragazzi ragazze
con capelli di merda so che siete in
tanti che guardate questo video io in
primis
ho sofferto di questo problema adesso
grazie a carla la finalmente i miei
ricci sono perfetti un prodotto che vi
lasciamo subito qua sotto in descrizione
per comprarlo a 7 euro e qualcosa su
amazon 426 g anche un materasso capelli
bagnati capelli asciutti non li
appesantisce di rifinisce fa un odore
pazzesco passeggiate sulle mani
dell'europa con le mani perché mi si
arricciano alle dita c'è poi uscite dal
mare dalla doccia che solitamente
sembrate gollum con questi road begging
spinge di qualcosa per farmi vedere se
sono un cesso come mi dicono fai un quiz
della patente non faccio inquisizione
valente da 14 anni li bocciano questo
nome falso falso melo pero dai fuori dei
centri abitati il conducente in caso di
fermata all'obbligo di collocare il
veicolo fuori dalla carreggiata
eventualmente su una pista ciclabile
parabola bandito vero o falso no alzo
alzo cosa già rotto il calcio dopo il
suo passo bisogna rientrare
immediatamente a destra rallentando
esame non superato hai fatto 12 errori
ragazzi comunque siamo arrivati alla
fine di questo video come sempre vi
chiederei di farmi sapere qua sotto se
ci sono altre cose che vorreste vedermi
fare nei prossimi guglielmo tell
mettete un pollice in su se anche voi
vorreste che guidò i miei gattini
riescano a trovare finalmente una
armonia ha detto ciò iscrivetevi a
questo canale attiva della campania
delle notifiche e vi bacio ci vediamo
domenica con una nuova puntata di cucina
buttata ciao
[Musica]